YURI GRINSHTEYN: Hello
everyone, and thank you
for joining us today
for this session.
This is OPS302.
We'll be covering
monitoring as code.
I'm honored to have Pod Sandhu
from the Schlumberger SRE team
here with us today.
Later in the session,
he'll be discussing
how his team and
others at Schlumberger
implemented the practice
of monitoring as code.
He'll also give
it to some lessons
that they've learned
in this journey
that we think you can benefit
from as you start yours.
Pod, thank you so much
for being here today.
PARDEEP SANDHU:
No thank you Yuri.
It's a pleasure to be here.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: My
name is Yuri Grinshteyn,
and I'm a site
reliability engineer
at Google Cloud on the customer
reliability engineering team.
So here are the topics
we'll be covering today.
We'll start by
understanding the basics.
We'll define the
concept of toil as it
relates to the practices of
site reliability engineering.
From there, we'll
cover the objectives
of as code practices.
Next, we'll review the specific
Google Cloud monitoring
entities that can be
automated and compared,
three approaches to automating.
I'll wrap up the first
portion of the session
by showing you a couple of
specific examples of automating
Cloud monitoring entities.
From there, I'll
hand it over to Pod
to cover the lessons learned
at Schlumberger, as they
have pursued this in earnest.
Let's get started.
So first, what do
we mean by toil
and why is automation important?
Well if we go back to our
fundamental principles
and practices, we'll recall that
site reliability engineering,
or SRE, is a specific set of
practices developed at Google
and since embraced everywhere
that hold user happiness
and appropriate
reliability at scale
as their ultimate objectives.
One of the major areas of focus
for both the more generalized
DevOps movement and SRE, which
is a specific implementation
of it, there's the focus
on automating as much
of the repetitive manual
tasks that specifically don't
add enduring value as possible.
Ultimately, our objective is to
achieve the appropriate level
of reliability for our services
and maintain that level, even
as user demand and
load increases,
without having to proportionally
scale the staff required
to support that service.
This is really the ultimate
value of focusing automation.
It allows us to reach much
greater levels of scale.
This is, of course, a
very simplified version
of the answer.
You can find much
more detail on why
we focus on reducing
toil in the books
we've published on the topic.
I'll particularly
encourage you to review
chapter 5 of the
first SRE book called
"Eliminating Toil,"
which discusses
this in much greater detail.
So now that we've covered
the value of automation,
let's talk about what we
mean when we say that we want
to treat something as code.
Here are the things we'll
be looking to accomplish.
Now a lot of this comes
from the infrastructure
as code principles,
but there's no reason
why we can't think
of monitoring as code
using the same exact language.
So first, we want to be
able to accurately determine
if there are any differences
between what we want
to be the key to our
monitoring configuration,
and what is actually
currently the case.
And so to that
end, we need a way
to precisely specify
the desired state
and be able to retrieve
the current state.
Next, we want our
work to be reusable.
We want to be able to create
modules and components
that other folks can use.
And again, we're in
pursuit of scale here,
and that can't happen if every
service team has to build this
from scratch, especially
in a model where
SRE is a shared service
across multiple service teams.
We want to use a declarative
approach to specifying
our desired state.
This means that
we want to define
the state we want,
not the set of actions
to take to get there.
Now, one of the benefits
of this approach
is that it's
[INAUDIBLE],, which means
that we can run our
automation no matter
what the current state is and
still be sure we'll arrive
at the correct end state.
This is different than
an imperative approach
where we specify the exact
steps that should be taken.
That might work best
for programming but not
for configuration.
And finally, in
part because we are
SREs who value software
engineering practices,
we want to treat these
configurations in the same way
we treat other source code.
One important thing
we want to achieve
is the other side of
the reusability coin.
We want to both share
our work and enable
others to collaborate
and contribute to it.
And this is where
code management
is incredibly important.
So I hope that you're now
convinced of the value
of automation in general and
applying as code principles
to configurations
specifically at this point.
The next logical question is
OK, how should we get started?
What can we actually automate?
So in Google Cloud
Monitoring, there
are four primary entities
whose creation, updates,
and deletions can be automated.
The first three are
available today,
and that's where most
of our focus will be.
They are uptime checks.
So this is a feature
of Cloud monitoring
that allows you to configure
synthetic checks to validate
things like URL availability,
website performance,
and TCP connectivity on VMs.
Alerting policies.
So I'll get into their
details in a bit,
but these are how you
configure Cloud monitoring
to actually send alerts
and notifications when
specific conditions are met.
And finally, dashboards
are collections
of charts folks use to
visualize the state of health
of their systems.
When looking to automate
Google Cloud Monitoring
configurations, you have
three primary options.
The first option is to use
either the Google Cloud APIs
directly or make API
calls in your code using
client libraries provided
by Google or third parties.
This works very well if you have
a robust software engineering
practice, and you
need to include
monitoring automation in
larger scripting or cognition
projects.
Your second option is to
use Google Cloud Deployment
Manager.
This is a fully managed
and hosted service
provided by Google.
It uses YAML as its
declaration language,
and the current state of your
configuration, once you apply,
is then stored in the Cloud.
You can interact with Deployment
Manager using gcloud commands
or its own APIs.
And then your third
option, and the one
I'll be using for our examples
coming up next, is Terraform.
This is an open source
toolkit provided by HashiCorp.
It uses its own language
for declarations.
But it has an excellent
multicloud support, which
is important for many users.
The open source
version, which is
what I'll be showing you
today, stores state locally
in dot tfstate files.
So these can be checked
with the source control
just like the main
configuration files.
So I imagine by now
this is probably
enough theory for everyone.
Let's get into some
specific examples.
Let's start with
a simple example
of creating an uptime check.
As you may recall,
uptime checks are
used to measure what
service or TCP endpoint
availability [INAUDIBLE].
Here's what our Terraform
file looks like.
There are five
things to note here.
First, at the very top,
we specify the provider
to let Terraform know that
we're working with Google Cloud
and to provide the project
we're operating in.
Next, we define the resource.
It's an uptime check.
In the http_check section,
we specify the path and port
to connect on and whether
or not to use SSL.
In the monitored
resource section,
we specify that we're checking a
URL rather than a TCP endpoint,
the host we want to connect
to, and the project where
this uptime check
will be created.
And finally, we specify
a content match string
we want to validate
in the response.
In the terminal, we'll run
the Terraform plan command.
It will validate
our configuration,
compare it against the current
state, if there is any,
and determine what resources
need to be updated.
Here, the plan is to
add one new resource,
as you can see in the
output at the bottom.
Once we've confirmed
that the plan is correct,
we issue the Terraform
apply command.
It will once again
provide the plan
and ask for an
explicit confirmation.
It will then provide the
specific resources that
were created, changed,
or deleted as a result.
And there we are.
We can now log into
the Cloud console
and validate that our uptime
check has been created.
If we want to clean
up what we did,
we can issue the
Terraform destroy command.
Similarly to apply, it
will create and validate
the plan of action.
It will then ask us
for a confirmation
before actually
destroying the resource,
and then let us
know when it's done.
And now we're back
to a clean slate.
Let's take a look at another
slightly more complex example.
Once we've created
an uptime check,
we may want to get alerts
if and when it fails.
Before we get into the code,
let's review the basics.
We're going to create an
alerting policy, which combines
both the condition
to be evaluated,
the trigger notifications,
and the mechanism
to be used for the
notification itself
or the notification channel.
Our Terraform code needs
to describe both of these.
So here's how we would
configure the policy in the UI.
We would use uptime check URL
as the resource and the check
passed as a metric.
We would then filter it through
just the check we care about.
We would use the
count false aggregator
to count how many of
the locations from which
the check is running
report failures.
Our condition will then
trigger if any failures are
reported within five minutes.
Here's how we would
write the Terraform
file to represent that.
Note that we specify the
notification channel first
with type email and
then email address where
the alerts would go to.
The output would then get
stored in the variable.
We then define our
actual alert policy
with a condition threshold.
There, we provide the metric
filter, the comparison
operator, and the aggregations.
And then finally, we specify
the notification channel
we've created up at the top
using the variable all the way
at the bottom.
When we run Terraform
plan, we see
that it's actually
going to create
two resources, the notification
channel and the alerting policy
that is going to
use that channel.
When we run apply, we
see that two resources
are created, as we expect.
As before, we can confirm
that our alerting policy
was created in the console.
We can also confirm that
the correct notification
channel was created and that
our policy is [INAUDIBLE]..
If we want to undo
what we've done,
we can again issue the
Terraform destroy command.
Note that this time, two
resources are destroyed.
Terraform is aware of
the dependencies involved
and destroys the
alerting policy first
and then removes the
notification channel.
I hope this served as
a good introduction
to the practice of
monitoring as code
and how to use Terraform
to automate and configure
in Google Cloud monitoring
for your projects.
At this point, I'll
turn it over to Pod
to talk about how the
SRE team at Schlumberger
put these into a
real world practice.
PARDEEP SANDHU: Thank you Yuri.
So I'm going to talk to you
about Schlumberger's monitoring
as code journey over the past
two years, starting with 2018.
At Schlumberger, there
are many solution teams
developing apps and services
for the Delfi ecosystem.
And each one of these teams
was creating their own version
of the monitoring framework.
What I mean is they were
creating dashboards or alerts
or even log-based metrics
in their own silos,
using different
coding languages,
or in some cases just
configuring through the UI.
In terms of the big
picture, it was obviously
great to see so many teams
taking monitoring so seriously.
But the problem was,
with this approach,
that very little code
was being reused,
which lent it to being hard
to build any best practices
or learnings.
And in most cases, word
of mouth or presentations
were the only way of showing
what each of the teams
were doing.
So what changed in 2019?
Well, a new central
SRE team was created,
and it's the team
that I work in today.
The purpose of this team
is to provide governance
and alignment across the various
solution teams in Schlumberger.
At the beginning of 2019,
we started brainstorming
of what we wanted to
focus on for that year,
and after reading various
books on SRE from Google,
we decided it should
be toil management.
After attending many
presentations and demos
of each of the
monitoring frameworks
from each of the
teams, we wanted
to merge the implementation
learnings into one toolkit.
So the idea of creating one
toolkit or one framework,
we believe it would allow
us to add new monitoring
capabilities that would
benefit all the teams using it.
One example of this was when
Google introduced the service
level monitoring APIs last year.
We could also ramp up
solution teams much faster
with the use of this toolkit
within their apps or services.
And by using the one
toolkit, we could
spread the message
of how we wanted
to monitor systems across
Schlumberger more consistently.
So the fun part.
Creating the toolkit.
So what did we do?
By taking the best bits of each
of the solutions monitoring
scripts, we created a toolkit to
work with the Google monitoring
endpoints.
Key to the design
of the toolkit was
to understand that
most teams already
had monitoring setup,
either through the code
or through the UI.
And we want to take the approach
of backing up and restoring.
Backing up the
aspects of monitoring
that they care about in the form
of JSON files using [INAUDIBLE]
and providing the ability
to restore from them.
Once we'd created the toolkit,
we needed a way of teams
to adopt it because
there's no point in having
a toolkit that no one uses.
So we created a second
git repo, which they
could fork from to get started.
And both of these Git repos
are an image in this slide.
Within the git repo, we
provided the necessary pipelines
to take our approach of
backing up and restoring.
We also provided the
monitoring controls
that will need to be in
place for all of our GCPs
for SOC 2 compliance.
And we also included
other examples
of how to monitor
different Google Cloud
technologies such as Pub/Sub,
Google Storage Datastore,
Google Load Balancer.
And for the teams that
were new to SRE practices,
we also included examples of
how to set up SLIs and SLOs.
Within the git repo that the
solution teams had forked,
they could also add their
monitoring configuration
that was specific to their app.
We inner sourced
both of these git
repos so that teams could
contribute new features,
fix bugs, or even provide
good examples of monitoring
certain aspects, which the
other teams may benefit from.
Each of these Git repos are
managed through pull requests,
which our team
approve because we
have the broad knowledge of how
all the other teams are using
the toolkit, and
we can give advice
on the best ways of monitoring
certain aspects of Google
Cloud.
Having everyone on
the same toolkit
gives us the agility
to be more dynamic
with either new technology
adoption or compliance
requirements.
So what are the key
takeaways from our learning
of our implementation?
I would ask you to go and
look at the Google git
repo in github.
There you would find
examples of how to back up
your alerts using Python.
And I think this
would give you ideas
of how to add monitoring as
code into your organizations.
So where are we today?
We believe that within
your organizations,
you can start by implementing
the following points that
are shown in this slide.
And within our organization,
by consolidating
into a single
toolkit or framework,
I'm going to explain
to you how we
have benefited by doing this.
Number one.
New solution teams are no
longer reinventing the wheel.
The learning curve
is less steep,
and the time spent is
significantly reduced
implementing monitoring.
Number two.
Monitoring is no
longer an afterthought.
The automated deployment
allows the solution teams
to implement monitoring early
in their product lifecycle,
enabling them to have the
insights into the reliability
and performance of the
critical user journeys
and metrics that they've
defined in their projects.
This will also improve the
solutions overall reliability
at the time of launch.
Number three.
Continuity and
continuous improvement
is achieved using
code rather than
having to update multiple
different documentation
sources.
And lastly, point number four.
The central support organization
has a consistent interface
for monitoring,
alerting, and reporting
across the various
solution teams,
both for operational and
business level needs.
This is an example of our
service level objectives
compliance dashboard
that we created in-house.
This gives us a single pane
of glass for both business
and solution teams on how
well our apps and services
are performing.
Each of the colored
boxes represents
wherever a solution
or shared service
is either in compliant,
non-compliant,
or possibly even
in feature freeze.
And with that, I'd like to thank
you for listening to me today.
And I'll hand it over to Yuri.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Pod, thank
you very much for that.
It was extremely informative.
I really appreciate
you being here today.
And thank you to
everyone for watching.
We hope that [INAUDIBLE]
found this useful,
and we certainly
would encourage you
to get started with
your own journey
toward monitoring as code.
Thanks again.
Take care.